wow how are you you look amazing that
song was beautiful camil I'm such a fan
of Legoland can I go with you oh my God
I really am a child cam I love Legos I
me too I just bought the R2-D2 and I'm
struggling it's for like 5 to 10 year
old oh so I didn't buy I did Yoda I've
done Yoda yod yeah I bought it for my
son but really I was doing it yeah I
don't have an excuse to buy it for
anyone else I I just own it like I it's
fun and it kind of is very um calming
and therapeutic I like putting it
together I heard though that you were
recently in Texas where I'm from I was I
was in Texas yeah were you shooting
there or just having a good time the
Lone Star State I was there promoting
this uh fabulous gin that is from Scot
that's the right state to do it yeah it
is they they like gin down there um we
were in Houston and Austin it was really
hot um and honestly the nicest people
the great food and the food food but you
have a new gin so let's let's talk about
I have this new gin it's uh called The
Wild the wild Scottish gin it's called
called The sassak Wild Scottish gin all
the Botanicals are from Scotland from
where I'm from in the southwest of
Scotland we've got toasted oats blabber
rhubarb Scott Pine Heather it's a really
balanced gin so we've been touring all
around the US pouring people Jin and
tonics and and having a damn good time
well I don't want to be left out so I
had them pour us one so here you go I
hope you made these nice and strong I
did well if I made it it would have been
but I guarantee you they were looking
out for Mama and it's not that strong
we like to serve it with a little bit of
Apple in there because we have apples as
our main Citrus but uh cheers I'm is it
like crab apple uh it is yeah I have
crab apple trees I I grow them at my
Ranch yeah yeah yeah used to pick them
you can't eat them because they're
really sour and um but they're great for
Jin obiously yeah well that's why I'm
growing them for Jin well we we inst it
is really good by the way um we saw this
photo of Sam in New York that I really
wanted to show everybody because I mean
are you trying to pick up every woman in
New York is that was that the goal
because I'm just saying like what do you
keep in the bag what's in the bag what's
in the bag it's like a really fancy
fanny pack I like it it's like the
Tardis I've got everything in there I've
got bottles of Jin and it's oh it's like
Mary Poppins there's so much room out
yeah no I I mean what can you get in
your SP that's a sparen uh keep your
mobile phone your lip salve and okay
anything else um crab apples maybe oh
crab apples there you go but you can't
eat them all right his new book is
called Clan land in New Zealand it's on
November 7
so I love that like you get it out get
it out what did you give these guys we
gave them your gy yes gave them your gy
no I love that you write a book and you
get to like go all over New Zealand
right like for this book yeah right yeah
I went to New Zealand um traveled all
over the islands and uh it's it's kind
of like Peter Pan's World honestly it's
got Alpine it's got glaciers it's got uh
amazing mountains fjords jungle what
flightless birds great white sharks
there's so much to do there it really is
an incredible place it's beautiful I
remember the first time I went there I
was like why do I not live here right
parts of it remind me of Scotland it's
got a real Scottish connection that's
kind of the reason I went there but um
it is mountainous it's it's an epic uh
epic country and you are the person that
goes to I'm the person that goes to a
place and like enjoys the scenery and
you're a person that Adventures around
right you do all the things that might
kill you yeah yeah yeah yeah I I dived
with great white sharks I jumped off
cliffs they have obviously they invented
bunge jumping in New Zealand they
invented zorbing if you don't know what
that is it's it's a big bowl that you
climb inside and then roll down a hill
it it sounds terrible it was great fun
if you the worst ride at a fair is what
it sounds like pretty you then could
fill the bowl with water or Jin maybe or
whatever you want now you've reeled me
in okay all right well I heard that the
the forward is Peter Jackson that's
amazing Lord of the Rings did you meet
while you were there like sure Peter
Jackson no we didn't meet him
unfortunately but um you my co-star gra
he had worked on The Hobbit many years
ago I was possibly named after a hobbit
my brother was named after an elf in
real life um so I was like this is meant
to be so we went to WETA where they
build all of the the animatronics and
the athetics and they actually made me
up to be a creature from lord of rings
in The Hobbit unfortunately it wasn't an
elf it was a dwarf I I got to play groin
groin the dwarf okay and uh it was quite
a transformation I know wait I want to
see the picture CU it's it it is quite
the transform there he is yes that guy
is not picking up a lot of women in New
York I don't know guy I mean well maybe
a particular kind I have to ask though I
heard this story I I love Egypt I've
actually been to to Cairo as well and I
heard you were there shooting a movie
and and you were on the top of a taxi
yeah normally you get in them but the S
hears me on top of a taxi pretending to
be on a horse so I'm driving around
Cairo doing this independent movie many
many years ago and I had to you know do
the horse acting and I feel like there's
a lot of horses maybe they could have
gotten like yeah yeah it was a very
cheap movie I was going to say I was
like you're I had to pay for the ride at
the
end like the Uber thank you five stars
oh my God I just imagine like where is
everyone watching you like on the top of
a car just what is this movie and can I
find it like what is
it I have one of those it's never I have
one of those too so wait you did um
theater when you were young right you've
been in this did you know when you were
very young that you wanted to do acting
like in I I was definitely interested in
it I didn't know I could do it I'm still
not sure if I can no but I um I did I
got into acting through theater and for
many years worked in on stage in the UK
and toured a lot and one show I did I I
toured around Scotland and it was a sort
of small stage much like this but
smaller um and I came on stage and and
during the performance I fell through
the stage because it was sort of a
temporary one and I had to carry on like
it was part of the show so like yeah I'm
sort of doing half a monologue like like
looking out at the audience like this
and then you became a hobbit you're half
of you you're half of you oh my God you
just kept going like you didn't climb
out my co-star just started laughing and
didn't stop but we had to just pretend
it was all part of it yeah oh my God I
would I'd laugh challenge yeah I'm like
one of those people that's on SNL that
laughs in the skits that would be me I
wouldn't be I'm not an actor so um well
we have a photo from that time that I
want to show so wait here we go oh look
at you you're like a little wee boy
young and innoc thank you I was 22 years
old there I love it oh my gosh I heard
that we have something in common so I
cannot stand helicopters I'm terrified
of them you don't like them either right
right listen I uh in New Zealand um had
to go on a a helicopter ride it sounds
amazing we went flew up 7,000 ft up into
Milford Sound um on top of a glacier in
the height of Summer talk about climate
change thankfully there's still glaes
there yeah and I was in a
kilt riding in a helicopter with a kilt
on can be a bit drafty I have to admit
but I I was I was standing on a glacier
in Commando so I I feel like it's a
first
rightand and I like how you say Glacier
um I like that I have actually stood on
it it was Portage Glacier in Alaska and
it's it is actually sad because now I
look back and like how it looked
whenever I was there it's even gone down
like since I was there as well but it is
I was terrified I took a helicopter up
to it and I was so terrified in the
helicopter I was like is this how I'm
going to go yeah I recently had to to
come back into New York via helicopter
it was amazing flying into the city it's
such an incredible City but the whole
time I was just staring at the captain
cuz he kept looking down I'm like what's
he looking at is something Broken Oh no
I was pretty freaked out yeah and if it
is I hope it's not the thing at the top
holding it all
[Music]
[Applause]
together thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home